about uh let's talk about some good news
that involves the royal family let's do
it we have this story from the daily
mail it has to do with meghan markle a
little bit will going woke make netflix
broke streaming giant could see shares
slump further after losing 970 000
subscribers as it was blasted over
canned meghan markle cartoon and
transgender pregnancy comedy
what oh weird well okay well here's the
good news i mean that i guess get we'll
go broke jeremy boring of the daily wire
tweets daily wire just surpassed disney
to become the sixth largest podcast
publisher in the country per podcast
that's awesome disney has a 100 year
head start on us it won't be enough as
the years roll on and their war on their
own audience continues
this is one of the biggest get woke go
brokes yet did you know that netflix
predicted they would lose two million
subscribers and they didn't so good for
them but they already know they're going
to be going broke i don't know if it's
because from the meghan markle fallout i
don't know i think it's probably because
um stranger things ended too oh so this
isn't bad is that an organic ad that is
a real a real netflix show
about a man who gets pregnant yeah it's
weird as they do but everyone was like
freaking out like they made a woke movie
and i'm like bro junior wasn't woke
remember junior with arnold
oh yeah he gets pregnant oh good lord
like did you watch the trailer for this
it's not about being transgender it's
about a guy who gets pregnant it's like
junior part two or like a reboot or
something so what's the what's the plot
there he like finds out he got pregnant
they're like well we don't know how it
happened but it did he's like oh no and
then it's a guy who's pregnant where
does the baby come out
i think they mentioned that in the movie
no his ass or something oh gosh that's
great
i'm pretty sure you would die it's like
kindergarten yeah but look look look
disney definitely get won't go broke
they wanted to play the groomer game
they can win it yeah now daily mail i'm
sorry daily wire is bigger that's kind
of crazy if you think about it the daily
wire is only what seven years old yeah
very young like seven decade i think
yeah it's kind of crazy that's
remarkable
here's what i see happening with the
daily wire netflix disney
these big companies
stood atop this massive shining hill
and everybody looked up at the shining
people in the shining hill and said i
longed to be a top there with you and
then one day people started walking off
the hill
while screaming about weird stuff that
made no sense
daily wire was like guys we can just
walk up like we they're leaving we'll
walk right up yeah they walked right up
and now they're standing there and
they're like wow look at that yeah these
people like walt disney spent his whole
life walking up the hill grinding
getting to the top and then once he's
there okay now he's like all right son
would you like to take a helicopter up
here with me so and the kids now the
kids that never had to climb the
mountain or on the top of the mountain
they don't understand the struggle and
people like ben shapiro and jeremy
boring have climbed the mountain to get
there those are the people we want on
top of the mountain that know how to
climb a mountain the mountain right and
the rest of it's just a skin suit it's a
corporate skin and it's the same as we
were just talking about some of these
politicians in the aocs there isn't a
lot of respect for the the patrimony for
the what was built
before i arrived i forget the name of
the current ceo of disney but he arrived
with a hundred years of this that other
people built and all you have to do in
terms of idea of patrimony and custody
is you have to hold it cherish it grain
to try to expand it but don't destroy it
and and since they didn't have to climb
that mountain to use the analogy since
they didn't have to work hard to become
members of congress they don't have a
love for it they don't have a risk but
they don't have an awe of it so they
think it's easy to just destroy it the
supreme court destroy put transgender
cartoons on for five-year-olds and it's
like well wait a second this isn't yours
you're just the custodian of it but nope
i'm gonna destroy it maybe it's just as
simple i mean people don't want to work
for someone else's project they want to
make their own yeah well they're making
their own all right but well so they're
destroying someone else's in the process
we entered this era of meritocracy with
the internet where people could make
their own channels one of the things we
often run into with hiring is that it's
like oh hey we need this job and we need
someone who's good at it
and it's really hard to find someone
who's good at it because anyone who is
good at it starts their own company
instead of working for someone else's
so like we're in that era of meritocracy
the internet has democratized the
process by which people can contract get
hired or make their own thing so who's
left to work at disney yeah woke weirdos
nobody wants that meanwhile people are
launching their own projects starting
their own youtube channels or at least
trying to do so yeah we talked about
maker studios before the show i was
involved with these people um lisa nova
ben donovan dan zipinski like on
we had the station 2007 youtube all
these really popular phil defranco dave
days we all came together to form this
like internet union of people which was
make which was uh the station then
became maker studios and when it became
a company then disney bought maker for a
billion dollars and they thought they
were getting all the talent all the
people that had been working through
maker but when they bought maker all
those people were like yeah you don't i
they left and then they realized we have
the name maker studios but we don't have
the talent that made maker studios great
this is the funniest thing like there's
things on youtube called multi-channel
networks which are mostly defunct these
days
and they'd be like sign with us
and we can get commercials put on your
video so you make money and we get a
percentage of it and then you'd be like
okay well i already have ads on my
videos why should i sign with you and
they say we'll protect you we can talk
with youtube it's a real advantage
and it'll be like x amount of time they
have no control over your content they
can't make you produce content that you
you're not signed to them with with
obligations on producing records or
videos or anything like that it's just
literally let us wrap your ad sales for
you disney buys it i remember when i was
working at fusion there were people who
genuinely thought they were like
when uh we're gonna walk we're into this
new project why don't we pull up our our
maker talent pool and i'm like what does
that mean and they were like they pulled
this pdf showing all of these youtubers
on maker and they're like we can get any
one of these people and i was like
sure you can get literally any actor you
want you want to get brad pitt just pay
him and they're like what do you mean
and i'm like these people don't work for
you you bought nothing you bought the
rights to sell ads in their content and
you don't sell ads you're a production
house and they were like you mean we
can't get these people to be in our
shows i'm like well yeah if you ask them
and pay them but at that point you might
as well ask brad pitt or tom cruise and
they were like huh they genuinely
thought buying the network was like
buying buying the towel a record label
yeah like the record like you were
assigned to this record label you have
to produce two albums we want this album
no like they could quit at any moment
you had no rights over any of it so
these companies have been completely
insane from the get-go and i think the
big issue for the most part is
two two things one they think wokeness
works because they don't care
and merit is driving people of real
talent away yeah i mean who why would
someone want to work for netflix
no and i wonder
and and how many of these people have
hired you know all of the woke
hr reps and the woke vice president of
of what's the acronym for
diversity inclusion
the i.e is that what it is right that if
you're the ceo you just hear these
people yammer at you all day all day all
day this is what we have to do and
ultimately you cave but you know what's
going to change them is is stock prices
look at you know we were right before
the show went on we were looking at
disney stock i remember where it was
where it went up to where it is now
i mean it's down almost almost 50
percent that that has to tell boards of
directors to say i don't care about your
you know if you think transgender 66.25
year-to-date if you think transgenderism
is the most important thing going the
markets clearly show something else and
so you've you've got to go because i
don't care about transgender i'm saying
this if i'm a board member i don't care
about trans i don't care about any of
this crap i care about making money and
right now you are not making us money so
you have to go but daily wire is making
money so i want to know why they're
making why we're not ultimately that's
what the board is going to be pushing
here's what it is i had i had a friend
who played in a band once i have a
friend who plays in a band i you know
don't really talk to a lot of my old
friends anymore but uh they played like
weird experimental music
and they were like we're gonna make it
big man because this is the future and i
was like dude no it isn't i was like i
understand the idea of doing
experimental music hoping you find
something new that becomes popular but
like pop music is pretty cut and dry as
to why people like it i was like look
right now
you're trying to sell a product to
people right you want to come buy it so
what's someone gonna buy your
experimental new spinach
and cheese ice cream
or chocolate
and they're like well spinach and cheese
is gross and i'm like maybe have you
ever tried it no okay well maybe it's
not gross you don't know you never tried
it how about matcha green tea
hey in japan they got a ton of that
stuff you've never tried it you might
you don't know if you'll like it or not
sounds weird though right it's
disgusting exactly you don't like it so
i said why don't you guys
if you want to be big and famous if
that's your goal why don't you make a
product you know people will like now
you want to do something new and unique
so you're not just making chocolate ice
cream you're making like chocolate with
salted caramel like something it's a
little different like salt in your ice
cream yeah but try it it is pretty good
this is what netflix is at right now so
what happens is you got an ice cream
company that makes delicious cookie
dough ice cream and everybody wants to
buy it but cookie dough ice cream is
making people fat so along comes these
young people who are like you're making
people fat young people don't like that
what they like is fresh vegetables you
should make our esg ice cream zucchini
cucumber
zucchini cucumber surprise it's the
right ice cream to have and then all of
a sudden no one's buying it but don't
worry you're not you're not actually
correct but you are morally correct and
the company implodes and then what
happens is the daily wire comes along
and they start selling chocolate ice
cream again because these people decided
not to you can't just think we're gonna
do this esg stuff and it's gonna work
because we are on top no
you there's two mountains there's esg
which is a pile of garbage and then
there's everest and you're like well if
we're on a pile of garbage we're still
on top yeah sure on a pile of garbage so
go for it leave the mountain behind
leave room for for timcast.com for daily
wire for other channels to start rising
because you've walked away from it
that's what they're doing yeah in the
name of vsg and other it really was in
the 90s you remember probably as
similarly if they decided what people
were gonna like next it was the the
marketing companies nbc disney cbs they
were like okay what's the next big thing
frizzy hair and hairspray whatever now
it's people are it's democratized i
guess is a way to put it and they don't
you can't keep controlling the mind it
doesn't work anymore people are free
their minds are free now people are just
it's become much more apparent
what works and what doesn't but in your
ice cream scenario which is what disney
is the company implodes because no one
wants their esg ice cream
but they still have production
facilities ice cream making machine
distribution networks that have value so
someone will swoop in and take it i'm
saying when it comes to disney their
theme parks have value their studios
have value someone's gonna swoop in and
be like this
we can't lose the value of these things
because you're running a crappy product
i know
you at home and maybe all of you here
have been driving down the street one
day and have seen an auto insurance
company in a building that looks
suspicious suspiciously like a taco bell
you've seen those right or a pizza hut
and it'll be like you know family
insurance center and you're like that's
a pizza hut
because at some point the pizza went out
of business yeah but there was a
building there and someone was like we
can use it we'll take it cheaper than
building one i you see all over chicago
you see like it's it's obviously a taco
bell but it was turned into something
else and you're like that's kind of
funny that's what we're gonna see with
disney yeah they got the ice cream
machines yeah but they're just cranking
out broccoli and
cheese
ice cream i mean broccoli and cheese is
good but as ice cream i don't know right
but they're also pumping out broccoli
and cheese ice cream but it says
chocolate on the label like thor
is it it's not that all these marvel
memories are like
you can call it whatever but it's just a
crappy well like
that's a little too much like thor
movie was weird but it was thor but it
was like kind of not thor because they
just made it wacky and wild
and it was like
sorbet with the colors yeah they could
have called him gore and made him have
like a an orange house or was the bad
guy oh okay then you could have called
him lore and it would have been like a
silver helmet well it's the same stupid
suit so disney's got the facilities to
produce all this stuff
when eventually they go out of business
like blockbuster
all those machines will be lying around
and people be like how much for that ten
thousand dollar camera twenty bucks i'll
take it well there is some great uh
statistic i'm sure we can pull it up but
of the 100 top companies in the year
1900 i think only one or two are still
around wow so so companies do rise and
fall right i mean standard oil is gone
uh you know general electric isn't it's
still around but it's not one of the top
100 yeah but i bet it's like they all
consolidate into one company that's
what's happening with the banks they're
consolidating yeah it was all still not
crazy so disney probably you know i mean
odds are it's not going to last 100
years i think it'll get bought by
blackrock
yeah everything will be brought by black
i wonder if blackrock's gonna buy an
entertainment the dutch farmers are
being bought right now by blackrock
what's that story oh we should talk
about they're trying to buy them we
should talk i mean some of these are
still around what uh standard oil
westinghouse ford union carbide general
electric uh a general electric dupont
standard oil att standard oh you said
twice yeah but but they're not sold like
the top 100 oh yeah it's in there twice
it is
standard oil nj standard oil and why oh
different new jersey new york standard
oil is rockefeller's oil company that
got broke up this is basically the first
multi like a monopoly
court case where they developed
antitrust to stop rockefeller all the
top companies are manufacturing and
resources
now what are the top companies we sent
that all to china that's right thank
goodness it'll be weird like uh and
they're not american either which is a
little bit confusing monsanto got bought
by bear bears motors
sears they have sears on this list but i
think it's unfair to say they still
exist because i think they do basically
doesn't matter
how why you know that company dao
chemical and they call it the dao
industrial average as if dao the company
has some sort of influence
yeah dow jones but this is just the same
isn't that just the same or something i
guess i would think it's not look it up
yeah
yeah
it's the same corporate name and dao's
like they make high fructose i mean they
make like i think you need to google
that before you say something like that
because you may just be wrong yeah they
might just be sometimes happening to be
a happy coincidence oh yeah you never
know like just because my name's tim
poole doesn't mean i have anything to do
with him but i did change my name to tim
fool by the way well that's what cracks
me up about when you find like this
healthy bar made by this company which
is owned by coca-cola which is owned by
and it's like so it's really not like
this i mean maybe the bar itself is
healthy when you're like this is some
local organic it's like nah it's not
it's all made in the factory by
dow jones or more precisely dow jones
and company is one of the world's
largest business and financial news
companies yeah this is dow jones
industrial average it's the same thing
so
charles dow dow jones so he basically
has co-opted the industrial
the economy by creating this industrial
average nonsense and naming it after his
own corporation
dow's insidious is dow dao
dow chemical is dow jones dow jones yes
no no he's not herbert henry dao created
dow chemical and charles dow created the
are they brothers they may be cousins
maybe
uh same person though maybe they were
secretly married and no one knew about
it yeah what were they like
henry dow you say one of the guys names
henry yeah henry dow and then the other
guy all i know is that they all used to
own great mansions they're from very
different places so i don't think
they're related one's from canada and uh
belleville canada west
and charles davis from sterling i don't
know are you related
it's nice when you can like
divest your responsibility by having
like a distant family member do it for
you or your son yeah you know
joe biden hunter biden this is growing
into quite the conspiracy that's great
just go with it herbert henry down
charles dow yeah how far back does he go
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you